kanada mit flug und herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal zusammen mit lisa anna nadine muss
zugleich ist aufsetzen ich möchte sie
jetzt da wird jedes gesicht
dann hatte ich mache heute eine
challenge bei der wir gleich einen
karton hier aufstellen und dann hat
jeder die anderen sieben gegenstände
vorbereitet und muss erraten was das für
gegenstände sind ohne die gegenstände zu
sehen sondern nur durch das erfüllen der
gegenstände verstand diese chef so
sandra dein erster gegenstand ist dafür
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das ist ein doppelkinn ein doppel bilden
das ist das ein cocktail messbecher also
steht noch 0 0
wenn die frau heute gegenstand
auf dem steinigen und mädels produkt ja
ist das so eine feuchtigkeitscreme ja es
ist nach maske ja irgendwie verständlich
noch nicht ganz verstanden
die kannten mich warten geht das nicht
so sehen die dann zweiter gegenstand ist
wer hier den starken die mal den
kompletten kartons das kann man doch
eindrücken und das aber keine option ist
es das teil was da unten immer zum
drücken ist
das ist für t
[Musik]
du hast die sonne reife zur arbeit genug
ich doch nicht ja auch einfach im wasser
und etwas isst du das wissen soll das
ist
ich dachte erst es ist eine tafel
schokolade aber ich glaube man kann das
nicht aufklappen und das ist sie
geschminkt deswegen was zum schminken
jahrhundert das ist so eine palette ich
weiß aber nicht genau wie das heißt aber
wir sind brauchst du liebst und palette
ja ich habe dabei raten koblenz denkst
du kriegst mich mit typen die sprachen
lernen dadurch okay für die nächste
gegenstand für dich ist das ziel sind so
fit wie die herren oder dem produkt
greift zu beginnen
[Gelächter]
das ist auf jeden fall glaube ich hab's
für die haare noch gewähr
ok ok wahrscheinlich genauso schnell wie
die tage zuvor
das ist entweder trockenshampoo ist es
trocken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine schwester hat genau das gleiche
und jammer dass wir noch immer gegeben
weil ich keinen bock drauf haare waschen
und vor allem bei trockenstress heißt du
das ding deo ist leichter bei den andere
konsistenz hat und die uns auch kleiner
ganz kurze imposant rat vor der aufnahme
gesagt hab ich keine pira produkt derart
meldet weil die so schwer sind
wenn ich auf jeden fall im foyer
produkte erraten das produkt ist aber
wirklich richtig sie uns kontaktieren um
eine nase juckt
[Musik]
ist auch so ein gewinn
das ist das ist gut
mehr noch klagen mittelmeer erschienen
ich kann nicht mal sagen das gewürz
richtig ist das sind keine was komme
kümmel wir mal überlegen und dann bitte
deine antwort und drei bei ein einhalb
stoppst du dir immer noch mal in die
nase wenn du krank bist dein badawi
heißt das noch mal das handy das ist
ich habe mir die kugel riesen packungen
kaminski aber ich geb dir einen halben
punkt wo sandra sein fünftes produkt ich
bin gespannt weil produkt das wissen ich
habe jedes produkt erraten
ich glaube das ist ein kleiner spiegel
hier drin ich hatte erst überlegt dass
es eventuell einen schreibstift
anspitzer fleisch tiefland sofort
ausfüllen sagen aber ich glaube das ist
sondern also hier ich glaube dass das
hat auch wenn ist auf jeden fall make-up
weil man kann das auch klappen dann kann
man ihn gewinnen pinselreiniger
irgendwas machen im gesicht und ist ein
kleiner spiegel
das würde ich sagen aber ich kann ja
nicht hingenommen haben sagen ich kann
es nur soweit beschreiben ich habe alles
richtig immer das ist ein kleines ding
zu hause ich kenne den begriff das
vorletzte produkte handy ist dafür
[Musik]
schwierig zu sagen jetzt mit einem dass
man das schwierigste produkte aber was
muss kurz trotzdem wenn man sich da ein
gesicht hat gar nicht wie controller ist
allerdings für die nintendo switch und
zwar ist das keine controller an schwer
sagen
switch gewünscht das ist ein fordert das
produkt
das ist ein viertel der eintrittskarten
kann ich dachte jetzt hat meine
eintrittskarte sind bus gewesen da
irgendwie so weit als dieser anlage
ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß es ebenso
tassen die kann zu drücken werden nur
irgendwas machen wird neben den ausgaben
für klavier
mein leben ist produkt werde ich auch
erraten
es ist auf jeden fall auch was zum
sprühen und haarspray
das ist für die haare und zwar ist das
so eine spülung die man dann aber alle
sprüht verschwinde ich hundertprozentig
was soll es denn sonst sein heißt denn
ein hitzestau
und das ist ja heiß und gut für die
haare und das ganze das müsst ihr dann
quasi jeder sich drauf spielen wir nicht
sehen
an der stelle wird es dann ja nicht das
heutige video zu beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann lassen einen
daumenbruch unter dem video das andere
[Musik]